MALE SPEAKER: Ladies and
gentlemen, I want to bring up
a good friend of mine.
He's going to perform for you
guys and just amaze you like
he amazes me.
Ladies and gentlemen, Darien.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - DARIEN, "COMPOSURE"]
DARIEN DEAN: How y'all doing?
How y'all doing?
Let's not get it twisted.
He's talking $30,000?
Talking about $10 to buy a
CD when I got $30,000?
Boy, you better listen.
Let's start this off, though.
Listen.
Hey.
[MUSIC - DARIEN, "COMPOSURE"]
DARIEN DEAN: We're going to
get to know each other
tonight, y'all.
We're going to get to
vibe, get to groove.
Short time, but we are going
to get to know each other.
You all are going to know me
as not the dude with the
$30,000, but the dude who was
trying to bring y'all a little
bit of independent soul music.
You know what I'm saying?
So we're going to do it as
little stuff like that.
[MUSIC - DARIEN, "COMPOSURE"]
[APPLAUSE]
DARIEN DEAN: Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you, y'all.
So my name is Darien Dean.
I'm very, very excited
to be here.
I don't know how many of y'all
have actually been in the
Google building before,
but it's a
pretty exciting building.
Ryan took me on a tour here
a while back, and it's
incredible.
I mean, they have like
a petting zoo, I
think, in the west wing.
And they paint your face
in the bathroom.
It's bananas.
Seriously, like it's crazy.
You got to get a tour
of this place.
It's real serious.
So, you know.
But no, real talk.
I'm very, very happy
to be here today.
I'm very happy to be here
during Black History
Month, to be real.
You know what I mean?
Especially as an independent
artist that really--
I'm into message music.
So having a month where I can
really listen to some
messages, not everybody is
always open to those.
So this is a good
time for that.
But speaking of messages, we're
going to get on to our
second message of the evening
from myself right now.
[MUSIC - DARIEN, "YOU"]
[APPLAUSE]
DARIEN DEAN: Thank you.
Thank you, y'all.
Thank you.
[MUSIC - DARIEN, "LOVE
REVOLUTION"]
DARIEN DEAN: I like
the groove.
Let it run some more.
[MUSIC - DARIEN, "LOVE
REVOLUTION"]
DARIEN DEAN: Yeah.
You know what?
I need more space,
a little more.
OK.
Talk to y'all.
Listen.
[MUSIC - DARIEN, "LOVE
REVOLUTION"]
DARIEN DEAN: Stop it.
No, wait.
No.
TIFFANY T'ZELLE: You're
not feeling it, right?
DARIEN DEAN: My thing is, if it
was [INAUDIBLE] day, that
level of enthusiasm would
have been fine.
But this is Black
History Month.
TIFFANY T'ZELLE: That's right.
DARIEN DEAN: So the sign
is-- you're right.
The sign is right there.
So I got to be real.
I got to be real.
I wasn't feeling that.
TIFFANY T'ZELLE: Me either.
DARIEN DEAN: The
energy was 63.
TIFFANY T'ZELLE: Not even.
DARIEN DEAN: It was
44, about 44.
So we're going to have to get
that other-- let me do the
math real--
56%.
That it.
Going to have to get the
other 56 from y'all.
But it could be that the problem
is me and my delivery
and the way we're doing this.
Or probably maybe y'all, too.
I mean, I'm not trying
to point fingers.
I'm not even.
So let's try this
again, shall we?
But let's try it again.
Let's just get it started.
[MUSIC - DARIEN, "LOVE
REVOLUTION"]
DARIEN DEAN: So maybe if I
give y'all the message
differently first and then we
try, can that work possibly?
OK.
Maybe.
I'm not sure everybody's-- some
of y'all look confused.
All right, we'll try it.
OK, listen.
Hey.
[MUSIC - DARIEN, "LOVE
REVOLUTION"]
DARIEN DEAN: That's how
you do a revolution.
So next time don't get caught
out there with your 44%.
You got to come straight
with the 100.
You might only get one shot.
My name is Darien Dean.
I want to thank y'all.
I want to thank all of y'all
for participation and for
giving me a moment to get up
here and do what I do.
I want to thank this incredible
band, Tiffany
T'zelle, Les Cleveland,
Andrew, Eli, they
just killing it.
Thank yourselves once again.
Be blessed.
Darien.
[MUSIC - DARIEN, "LOVE
REVOLUTION"]
RYAN LOREN: Tell us about
yourself, where you come from,
your heritage, and what Black
History Month means to you.
Because this is a celebration
of Black History Month.
DARIEN DEAN: Absolutely.
Well, my name's Darien Dean.
I'm an independent soul artist
out of Mount Vernon, New York.
It's a great time to be an
independent artist, especially
one who has message-driven
music.
And during Black History Month
I have an opportunity to
really, really showcase some of
the message music that I'm
putting forth.
So right now I'm in the process
of working on a new
record, "Notes From the
Journey," but my previous
record, "If These Walls Could
Talk," had a song called "Love
Revolution." And I was able to
really tour with that song and
move throughout the country with
it really, and really not
just have it be a month, but
have it be something that is a
lasting effect and goes
wherever I go.
So it's nice to have the month
to focus, but for me it's kind
of like a constant journey.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
That's good to hear.
And what's the new album
going to be called?
DARIEN DEAN: "Notes
From the Journey."
RYAN LOREN: "Notes From
the Journey."
DARIEN DEAN: Indeed.
RYAN LOREN: Cool.
All right.
You've been on the
indie scene.
I wanted to ask you what is it
that you think-- there's so
many talented people in
New York and overall.
What separates those who have
the talent, but those who get
more exposure, those who
are more successful?
What's going on out there?
Like what separates the
good from the better?
DARIEN DEAN: It's crazy,
because there
are a lot of talented--
I mean, I see you on a regular--
we're out and on the
scene and seeing the talent
that's out there.
So it's not necessarily like
something that's split via the
talent at this point.
I mean, there's a lot of
political stuff going on in
all areas of music, not just
independent music.
I think the artists that hustle
the most-- and by that,
I mean they're consistent and
they're working and putting
out the best product
that they can--
eventually do get a bit of a
foothold and move forward.
But I think we're still at a
space where we do need some
taste makers with a little bit
more power to step up and make
some moves for these artists.
Because I always say, if I've
got to step out of the
kitchen, I can't cook.
And that becomes part of the
issue in being an independent
artist, is that you have to
juggle so many things, be good
at your craft, but at the
same time go out there
now, do this hustle.
And there's a myriad of
musicians at this point, and
that actually makes it
difficult as well,
RYAN LOREN: Definitely,
definitely.
So can you describe your music
for those who might not know
about you that are going
to be watching,
and are here tonight?
DARIEN DEAN: Indeed.
Well I mean, my music is an
amalgamation of all the things
that I've come across.
I mean, I started
off as a dancer.
I was a choreographer, and
I was deep into hip-hop.
So definitely have those
hip-hop roots that
are infused in there.
I've been traveling.
The musicians that I play with,
they range from church
musicians to jazz musicians,
so they add their flavor.
But at the end of the day,
the kind of music
that I write is--
I'm really into the craft
of songwriting.
So I try to present stories.
Hence the titles, "If These
Walls Could Talk," "Notes From
the Journey." Most of my songs
are stories about life that
I've either come into contact
with people and had
discussions, or my own life.
So that's pretty
much the range.
But again, infused with a bit
of hip-hop and a bit of jazz
and fusion kind of thing.
RYAN LOREN: Cool.
Yeah, and I think when I first
heard your album title for the
first one, it actually evokes
an image in my head.
DARIEN DEAN: It's a
visual for sure.
RYAN LOREN: And I think it's
really cool that that's how
you approach things.
DARIEN DEAN: Absolutely.
RYAN LOREN: So we're at Google,
so I'd like you to
talk a little bit about
technology.
I know you're a techie.
DARIEN DEAN: Oh, you
know I'm a techie.
I'm into this.
This is my thing.
I mean, technology has been
really helpful in my journey.
And I didn't get into
it after the fact.
I had always been.
But it just helps so
much in what we do.
As an independent musician,
you're always fighting a
budget battle.
It's always a budget thing.
So the more that you're able to
do on your own, the better
it is for your pocket.
And so in doing things like
mixing the album, I have my
own setup, and we do that kind
of thing at the house.
For instance with Google tools,
like some of the things
that I do, there was a point
where I was writing songs on
random pieces of paper
everywhere, and I just could
never find them and piece
them together.
And even later on, I got into
something where I was writing
songs on my laptop, but I might
not have it with me, so
now I'm doing something
here or there.
But one of the things that I use
now is Google Drive, and I
actually write songs, and I'm
able to get into the cloud and
basically add to them from
wherever I am, my phone, my
iPad, whatever.
So those are the kind
of things that help
me get things done.
I find myself writing faster,
and I find myself getting my
ideas out more clearly because
I'm not looking for this scrap
and going, I know there's a
good scrap here somewhere.
That's where I'm at sometimes
with this.
So it's been really helpful,
absolutely.
RYAN LOREN: Yeah.
Yeah.
And I know as a songwriter,
you never know when you're
going to get that idea.
DARIEN DEAN: You never know.
RYAN LOREN: So if you have the
phone and it all syncs, then
it works out really well.
DARIEN DEAN: Absolutely.
RYAN LOREN: Cool, I'm
glad to hear it.
Cool.
So, I just wanted to thank
you again for being here.
You have the album coming out.
When should we expect that?
DARIEN DEAN: As an independent
artist, I don't
have the exact date.
That's how it goes.
But I will say I'm really,
really amped
about the new project.
I have some incredible people
working on it with me.
And I've been able to, I feel,
really build off the last
record and build my
skill set even.
And so I can't wait
to present it.
I'm really excited about that.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
Well, we're really excited to
have you here, and can't wait
for the performance.
And I wish you all the best.
And thanks for your
honest music.
DARIEN DEAN: Thank you
once again, man.
RYAN LOREN: All right, man.
DARIEN DEAN: All right,
that's cool.